hi today I am speaking with Veronica
Mark I've spoken to her before and uh
she is a bit of a Globetrotter as we
will soon discover and we are going to
talk about
English as an international language
and uh Veronica first of all let me say
if you enjoy these videos please
subscribe click on the bell for
notifications and if you follow me on a
podcast service please leave a comment
hi Veronica nice to see you again yeah
hi thank you thank you for inviting me
here
all right so uh let first of all let's
catch up on your history since the last
time we spoke so many of our listeners
won't realize just by listening to you
that you're not a native speaker of
English your English is phenomenal but
of course you're not a native speaker of
English you're an example of
International English
and which is going to be the subject of
our conversation but update us on on
what has happened to you since we last
spoke
yeah so since we last spoke I moved to a
different country because
um yeah last time I was living in Russia
in Moscow I was actually learning
Chinese I was still a college student
right now I'm not a college student
anymore I graduated from college and I'm
just working on YouTube making videos
for people to learn English and right
now I live in Mexico City yeah so a lot
of machines what is it yeah what is the
name of your YouTube channel
so I have two YouTube channels the one
where I teach people English is called
English with Veronica Mark and the
second one is just Veronica Mark just my
name
and what what's different between the
two channels the difference is English
with Veronica Marek is focused on
teaching people English so I share tips
on how I managed to improve my English I
help people improve their English and
Veronica Mark is just lifestyle
basically I speak English there too but
it's more like oh I went traveling there
you know follow me or I did this it's
more like lifestyle content yeah okay
so and you said you were learning
Chinese are you still learning Chinese
and are you learning any other languages
or do you speak other languages
apology stopped learning Chinese just
because I I had to move to a different
country Mexico and I didn't speak
Spanish at all at first so now I'm
learning Spanish like every single day
so this is definitely my goal to learn
Spanish yeah
how good is your Spanish right now if
you go out into the street if you need
uh you know help in finding your way or
you walk into a store or perhaps friends
that you have are you able to function
in in Spanish yeah I'll be okay yeah my
Spanish is not amazing definitely not
I've been learning for like six months
now
but yeah I I know my way around it I
would say yeah all good okay now it's
interesting uh I was just chatting with
someone and how the most commonly spoken
languages in the world are of course
the languages of the imperialists call
it the empires you know why do people so
many people speak English French Spanish
Portuguese Russian
quechua even in Latin America which was
spread by the Inca Empire so Empires
tend to spread their languages
but perhaps no language has become as
dominant as the English language
so because for me English is it's
essentially my native language although
I was born in Sweden but since the age
of five I've lived in Canada
so as a non-native speaker of English
what is the attitude of the person
learning English do they learn it out of
necessity do they learn it out of
Interest
what's the attitude towards this idea
that this language above all others a
language which is no better than any
other originally spoken by people who
live on this
Foggy Island in the North Atlantic why
do we have to learn English like what is
the range of feelings that people have
when they are confronted with having to
learn English I think right now it's
mostly out of necessity because even
when it comes to your hobbies if you're
interested in cooking there are so many
recipes in English uh if you're a
professional athlete and you want to
like advance in your career you will
have to learn English just to be able to
travel to communicate to different
coaches for example so I think right now
it's even if a person is just like oh I
like English I'm interested in English
but one day they will have to they will
con like they will have to I would say
they will they will be in the situation
where they were like okay like I need
English I need English for work for
um studying I want to study at a better
University or I just want to move to a
different country and I need English
yeah but now the sort of learning out of
necessity that's not necessarily a great
motivator it's at least it's not a
positive motivation it's almost a
negative motivation
so does the average from your experience
and you have a lot of people who follow
you on YouTube are people able to find
some positive motivation something
positive about learning English that
encourages them encourages them along
the way
yeah that's uh very interesting actually
because I feel like this is something
that I'm experiencing with Spanish right
now because I started learning Spanish
because of necessity because I had to in
Mexico City yes you can just live with
English but it will be very difficult so
I would say that yes it's not enough of
a motivation to learning languages
because of necessity and I think people
who follow me on YouTube or Instagram
most of them learn English because of
necessity but I think what makes the
journey a lot more enjoy enjoyable is
finding resources that they like for
example
um what helped me I learned English
because of necessity because of my
education in college I had a lot of
subjects in English so I would at home I
would like watch YouTube and English and
for me that was something that would
give me a lot of enjoyment and pleasure
and satisfaction I would be like oh I
love it this is the way I like learning
English so even though for most of my
subscribers yes it's like I need English
because of my work however the paths
they take are often like different some
people are like oh I only want to focus
on business English but other people
like no like I'm okay with exploring
different subjects different using
different resources so I guess it just
depends on the person yeah
yeah and I would say too that if you
really try to just focus on business
English you won't succeed exactly we
have to have a general broadly based
sense of the language before we can
start focusing in on on business English
I always laugh when people are going to
teach you business English yeah there's
English you've got to learn English yep
um and it's quite true that that in
every language you know if you're in the
beginner material a lot of the people
that write textbooks try and push stuff
at you that they think you should know
you should know these Japanese festivals
you should know you should be interested
in this or that people might be
interested in something completely
different so nowadays you're able to
find stuff of interest and uh you know I
always quote the French expression La
Petite the appetite comes with the
eating and once you get into a language
then you discover things that are of
interest to you but
it remains that English is the language
with perhaps the greatest amount of
content available on the internet
Spanish is not is very good Russian by
the way has a lot of stuff uh you know
and and particularly for me that I enjoy
19th century literature you can find
books for free and uh excellent quality
audiobook produced in Russia and so
different languages on the other hand
Persian and Arabic is a lot harder to
find stuff and um it is important and
it's very helpful when there's an
abundance of of content hopefully with
audio and text available that something
in there is going to be of interest to
you
um another subject on in English you
know sometimes you hear well you know
the sanglo-saxon imperialism and
everybody's speaking English is no good
so we should all learn Esperanto
ah
I have trouble with that because I
personally find Esperanto like I've
never met a native speaker of Esperanto
now people are coming oh yes I've known
so and so he raised his kids on
Esperanto but that's not true uh there's
no culture there there's no food there's
no place called Esperanto land yeah so
we're kind of we're left with English
and if you get on a plane has happened
to me I was in Brazil flying from Iguazu
to Rio and the fellow sitting beside me
was a Ukrainian who had been living in
Brazil and we spoke Ukrainian
you're you're not gonna sit beside
you're far more likely to find someone
sitting beside you on an airplane who
speaks English than just about any other
language yep and so like it or not you
know we're stuck with English and it is
kind of useful but I can see where
people who are not native speakers feel
it unfair do you sometimes think it's
unfair that everyone has to learn
English why doesn't everyone learn
Spanish or Russian or Chinese oh well
this question of whether or not it's
unfair I just think that life is unfair
in general like when people try to be
like oh it's fair it's unfair
I mean it is how it is and there is
nothing we can do about it if you just
sit there and say oh it's unfair like we
have to learn English why not my native
language well you either just sit there
and whine about it or you actually go
and learn English because English will
always be there people will always be
learning English and uh yeah that's it
like unfortunately that's the reality we
live in so you either learn English or
you don't learn it I mean it's your
choice you miss the point yeah and it's
not really a political statement either
if a if a Japanese person
meet someone from Brazil they're going
to speak English
it's just a practical matter this is how
else are they going to communicate the
Brazilian is unlikely to speak Japanese
the Japanese person is unlikely to speak
Portuguese so it's they're going to use
their hands and and gestures or they can
speak English so yeah I agree with you
it's a practical solution
there are Regional languages like but
even there I think in Latin America
yeah they can speak to each other in
Portuguese and Spanish and they more or
less understand each other so that's
that's okay too yeah
so what are your plans now you're going
to continue with your platform on
YouTube and you can learn Spanish when
you become as fluid in Spanish as you
are now in English are you going to
start a YouTube channel for learning
Spanish
um
I haven't thought about it yet to be
completely honest uh when it comes to
English for sure I want to continue
making videos because I mean even right
now as I'm a non-native English speaker
I can see how much I have improved since
our last video for example because I
watched like our last interview a couple
of days ago I was like wow my English is
lot better right now so making videos in
English on YouTube has definitely helped
me a lot
when it comes to Spanish uh probably not
because
um it's enough for me with just one
language just sharing my journey with
people because I have been learning
English basically my whole life with
Spanish it's more like I don't want to
get super super Advanced I just wanna be
able to live in Mexico City and use some
phrases in Spanish and I think that's
enough for me
okay and and we can end on that note
however if you were to do a video about
your struggles in learning Spanish as an
adult
uh I think it would be quite interesting
yeah because
I mean as you say you've been learning
English your whole life there's a lot of
English in schools everywhere around the
world now you go to a country where they
speak Spanish which you didn't have at
school and so you're starting from
scratch and and what's that experience
like it would be an interesting uh and
and showcase a bit of Mexico City and
stuff that would be fun anyway that's
entirely up to you so but at any rate
thank you for taking the time and uh I
think your level of English is
astounding and yes even better than it
was before and I think that illustrates
several things first of all I mean I can
detect traces uh of sort of non-native
the slightest slightest suggestion that
you're not
um a native speaker but your English is
astounding
and the biggest thing to me is that I
have the feeling that no matter what I
say no matter how quickly I speak you
will understand everything I say
and that is the to my mind the most
important goal is comprehension because
for the native speaker speaking to
someone where you have the impression
they don't really understand you that's
very unsatisfying that's not a good
feeling whereas I can talk to you as
soon as I want and you can understand
everything I say yep that is that's very
very good and you have definitely
improved so no matter how good we are we
can always improve that's the other
message yeah yeah yeah and I know that
as a non-native speaker I will always be
improving as long as I study English I
will always be getting better and also
actually recording myself like having
all of those videos or even like quick
audio messages that I sent to other
people that I can later refer to
motivates me a lot because I'm like oh
my God a year ago I sounded like this
like I didn't know all of these words
but now I feel so much more confident I
speak a lot faster I know all of these
words so yeah like having all of those
videos and all of those references
really does help me like motivate me to
study English even more
yeah and you know it's not only the fact
that you know all these words the way
you assemble your words is in the
correct order uh
so many people and it that's more
important than accent is is having a
sentence structure with the odd Clause
buried in another Clause but yet
everything is English it's not Russian
or it's not German or Chinese it's it's
actually 100 English so congratulations
thank you all right thank you Veronica
nice chatting thank you yeah thank you
bye bye-bye